[Music]
hi everyone welcome to the annual
freezin round table webathon video bonus
episode
i'm matt that's nick that's cat oh god
don't touch nick
um this is gonna be fine we've spent a
lot of time in each other's company over
during the pandemic we have absolutely
forgotten how to behave hi how is
everybody doing i'm matt hi matt here
happy webathon yeah that's enough
moderation um what we're gonna do here
is uh you sent a bunch of questions and
we're going to answer them um in years
past we've given soliloquies about uh
how much reason has meant to all of us
individually uh careerly and in the
world
might come up again or try to get
through as many questions as possible in
the meantime some to the gang some to
those of us individually let's start
with brandon let's go
to brandon oh really
brandon writes can you make a case and
we'll direct this at katherine to begin
with can you make a case for why
libertarians should intellectually
engage with mainstream journalism
certain types of libertarians seem to
have a tendency to immediately dismiss
any source because of real or imagined
biases that are connected to a publisher
that is considered mainstream like the
atlantic new york times or washington
post
again all the places where peter
scooterman's wife is working uh reason
on the other hand seems to more deeply
interact with check with content from
such sources in ways beyond simply
mocking them when they get things wrong
what value do you find there is in doing
so for a libertarian audience yeah i
mean i think the answer is is kind of
obvious which is that if we want to have
more libertarians then we should talk to
and about
people and publications that aren't only
libertarian that don't already agree
with us i think dismissing a publication
because it has bias is the wrong
approach and i say that not least
because i edit a publication that has
bias like we we just happen to put our
bias on the tin we sort of say it up
front hey here's what we're doing here's
why why we're doing it
on the tin that's what they say it's
what it says on the tin on the label
i'll translate it to american for you
um and
um you know i wish that the atlantic and
washington post and others were maybe a
little more upfront about their biases
but i think that that that is not a
reason to engage with the legitimate
factual claims that people make with the
analytical
uh problems that they posit and and yeah
we want to be part of i think nick
gillespie can agree we want to be part
of a conversation we want to get a
conversation go actually want to
dominate the conversation
the brontosaurus approach doesn't work
for the friendly brontosaurus is not is
not um
a journalistic
tool i do think there are generally
speaking two types of uh in almost any
subculture but certainly a libertarian
one of people who want to
kind of take over the world in a
positive way of course that means you
know we take over the world and leave
them alone but you want to influence the
mainstream culture and you want to kind
of integrate into it so that they become
more interested in and uh reflective of
libertarian beliefs there's another
subset which almost sees and you know
this this comes up a lot in like indie
music scenes where it's like when you
know when when u2 or rem went from
smaller labels to big bad warner
brothers or national labels they sold
out right it's like no you know this is
about society and it's about changing
things and like you can you can be a
small band of you know perfectly pure
perfectly clean
usually kind of uninteresting and insane
people because you only talk to people
who agree with you or egg you on to more
and more extreme points of view or you
can be more open-ended and actually live
your life and try and persuade people
who don't agree with you this is a
better direction to go in so that's the
argument for
engaging always with the with the
mainstream to change it and maybe also
to break it up into smaller and smaller
things so there's less of a mainstream
which is one of the great triumphs i
would argue if libertarian thought over
the past 40 years i will say
professionally i think like i deeply
believe in this engagement strategy and
the kind of like if anyone wants to join
us in any part of the of the coalition
that's great personally i have a hundred
percent stop trying to convince the
people in my life of anything sure like
i'm just tired this is uh we're going
straight into the therapy session we're
going straight to the therapy session
that's what this special thought episode
is about right
um
i would point out so in 2008 was when we
first started the webathon um and i
think we've already exceeded our 2008
numbers so thank you very much for
donating to this 501c3 um but we also
that was the 40th anniversary uh issue i
was newly uh editor having uh been given
the baton by nick gillespie uh and we
did a oral history of reasons magazine
pursuant to this because it's an early
point when uh bob poole manny klausner
and tibor mccann took over management of
the magazine from uh uh
from
should remember that name um
they uh were covering they had a little
uh internal newsletter that covered the
libertarian party which is another
question that comes up always in these
things um and all the infighting we'd be
surprised to know that the libertarian
party was was infighting even back in
the early 70s um and uh it created a lot
of sort of tension and they had a
decision to make uh should we be the
kind of you know in-house magazine for
libertarianism
purely or should we be what they called
an outreach magazine of trying to get
involved in the larger media
conversation and they chose decisively
uh on the outreach and i think it was
the before
me uh i think for the institution the
right decision
amen all right let's direct this to
peter this comes from kevin from cedar
rapids
with the rollouts of the coveted
vaccines over the past year
when each of you became fully vaccinated
what was the first big normal thing he
said thing not dog first big normal
thing you did entertainment-wise it took
a little while to get new dogs uh this
year but no uh the first thing i did was
i went back to the movies and i went
back to uh a theater theaters in deep
washington dc had been closed for much
of last year and for the beginning of
this year and i went back to the
georgetown amc and i saw the bob
odenkirk john wick film uh nobody right
people were referring to it as bob wick
and it was it was exactly what i wanted
to see because it wasn't a great movie
but it was witty and violent trashy fun
kind of what i really enjoy about movies
in a lot of ways or just sort of the
regularity of movies something that is
just sort of um a cheap but engaging
entertainment uh that took you know it's
like a short movie it's like 89 minutes
or something like that and i went back
and i you know this was i think nine
days after my first shot so i don't even
know if i actually had any antibodies
but i was like i am done i'm ready to go
and it was super wonderful just to be
sitting there with a friend and with a
bunch of strangers who were like
watching a movie that we all enjoyed
nick what did you do i don't really
remember because by the time the
vaccines came i had already started
reliving my life for the most part i do
remember going to uh greenwich
connecticut living in new york city the
theaters were closed connecticut opened
its theaters briefly um and so i took a
train up to greenwich connecticut to see
tenet uh you know the horrible movie
uh that was one of the first big movies
to come out in a theater and it was
myself and about five other people did
you fall asleep yes i did and the real
problem was that when i woke up tennant
was still going on
actually it had restarted yeah
it doesn't matter i followed the movie
just as well as the people who pretty
much i think i got it better better and
then i also did this guys i totally make
sense it is a horrible movie and it's a
chris it's christopher nolan's walk of
shame uh luckily nobody saw it so uh and
then i did the same thing i went to new
jersey because the theaters in new
jersey were open and i went across to
jersey city and i saw the new mutants
which had been held on the shelf for
like 30 years it was so bad and then
they released it when nobody could go
and that too was a disappointment so
then i stopped going to movies and i
decided to live life damn it
but live life means take drugs catherine
what did you do on your uh i strongly
dislike being cold and so most of my
pandemic like the besides of course
the hundreds of thousands of deaths uh
the big cost of the pandemic for me
was that i had to socialize outdoors and
i i hate being cold so there was like a
lot of dumb
like
we'll all sit around a fire pit with our
gloves on and like pretend like this is
okay
just like so many cocktails it didn't
help and um so the the thing that i did
after i was vaccinated i'm sorry my
cocktails always helped yeah i mean it
was
that's true but um
having having people to my house indoors
to sit in my house with me yeah and eat
food like that that's all i want i'm a
simple woman
and uh and that's what i did on the
pandemic kind of like nick in that uh i
like by july of 2020 it was sort of back
to normal and it's just you you did what
you could get away with but uh beyond
that it was sort of doing it i went back
and looked at my calendar to see if
there was uh what was my big activity
and uh i went to uh kat timp's wedding
reception uh it was my first like at a
speakeasy hotel in new york with all the
youths being all youthful and without
their masks and stuff um but uh yeah i
was already doing things um eric
asks with a k
that's with c okay
uh not a ck which isn't the best
performance we all know i fondly
remember as a child as the christmas
season approached my mother would drop
on the coffee table the christmas
catalogs from all the department stores
can we guess eric's age
uh i would spend i think he's still
living with his mom though i would spend
batting then an evening with a red
marker circling the items i wanted then
turning that into a written santa list
of my very favorites didn't take long
before the reality of the santa
falsehood to become apparent speaking of
therapy yeah yeah
of the question on the windup what would
be at the top of your
santa list of things that you would like
changed in american government and or
politics catherine
uh that was a very it was a very matt
welsh question it was like where is this
gonna go yeah this is gonna go and it's
to me um
i
i think it's just could cui please stop
spending all the money like i it's a not
a not doing a thing request which
frankly i think a lot of things on my
real christmas list would be like could
people please stop doing things um but
you know you never get those under the
tree sadly um i do
um
there's there's this sort of like little
uh mini industry in like forums where
they ask you how we're gonna fix
democracy that i've like done many of
over the years and uh my answer to those
is typically some version of like could
we be nicer to each other could we find
ways to be nicer to each other um which
is which is essentially a concern about
polarization like i i do
think
as i've said on the podcast that that is
a thing that is
has always been bad but is sort of a
slightly different and worse form of bad
than it was before
so i guess what i'm arguing for is more
dinner parties
inside my house where it's warm um
but um stop spending the money like we
don't we are we are super duper out of
money like wow are we out of money like
like but we just keep making more we
keep and like
the inflation is like lurking behind us
and uh and the
um
the fact that that seems to matter not
at all to the people in charge in
washington is continues to kind of shock
and surprise me even after all these
years like a column still but for money
right you just sort of keep putting more
in and then whiskey just comes out the
other or like a solera system yeah
that makes something good
and this money does not
nick you're haunted by the death of
santa um yeah i was gonna i thought we
were gonna talk about cadillac's growing
up as kid because i can tell you that uh
when the sears wish book would come
around once a year
uh it was this fat phone book and i
realized already i'm talking in double
things that most people don't remember
yeah but if you don't tell me about that
and white pages together of everything
that was available from sears and the
the great things there matt and you'll
appreciate this were that you could get
any nfl team any major league baseball
team any nba team they would have the
uniforms or the shirts the merchandise
those teams which you know you were
always subjected to whatever shitty
metro area you lived in and i grew up
when the you know the jets and the
giants sucked and the yankees and the
mets sucked and that was like all you
could choose from you know so i was that
was like for me that was when i started
thinking about super abundance without
thinking about that that's i want to
live in a world where you know you can
purchase any nfl team across state lines
yes yeah purchase some vikings like like
you know you should be able to uh
uh purchase uh health insurance you know
speaking of health insurance
what's your big one santa oh my big
catalog is musician's friend from the
1990s which i spent hours and hours
pouring over like learning the details
of every amp and analog 8-track system
that was like that was you know sold on
the market in 1998 um and then i became
me uh no
[Laughter]
my uh uh
so this is like a this is a stretch goal
as they say
but
it's transform
all of the universal old age
entitlements into targeted benefits for
the poor and
uh special needs people right and to do
it over time i'm not saying like which i
i actually would not if even if i could
uh choose to do this like tomorrow i
think that would be a bad idea it would
be bad for the polity but to like
set a date some number of years from now
and to no longer have medicare or social
security as we as we know them but
instead to have
programs that benefit people who have
clear needs that are demonstrated um and
to to uh
to make our social spending about that
and that would in a lot of ways solve
catherine's problem of spending all the
money okay we're asking for the same
president i would uh uh just channel my
inner clark neely
and say uh end coercive plea bargains
oh that's very specific
potentially do you have a uh legal issue
that we're going to be learning about in
the new year
speaking of which donate to reason so
that we can pay for matt's legal defense
uh luke another great name uh always i
always like if we were gonna have a boy
i was always uh arguing for luke luke
welch that's good luke welch is very
good it's like a mouthful i don't know i
like middle names
male names that are one syllable yeah i
agree
um so uh
lots of nice words about podcast uh oh
yeah luke donated
today
so this is why luke got to the front of
the line not only that luke donated a
kidney to reason that's right we know we
don't think you should have to donate a
kidney we want him to be able to sell
his kidney on the free market and then
give us the money who are we to judge we
we prefer
luke luke is thanking us for the
excellent podcast first visited
reason.com when eugene vollock and his
co-conspirators came over to your site
like five years ago
it's been a while
and since then i've been consuming more
and more of your catalog
my question musician's friend my
question is about libertarianism's place
in the broader liberal
coalition i think of libertarianism as a
fundamental liberal ideology and wish
that i could more easily convey that
idea to my non-libertarian friends and
colleagues on the left they see
libertarianism as a far right ideology
even though many libertarians myself
included have more in common with those
on the left than on the right so my
questions am i wrong does libertarianism
have a place in the modern liberal
coalition what is the elevator pitch for
libertarianism as a liberal or left
ideology catherine
i think that uh the the pitch at least
is to kind of start with
what we have in common with people who
conventionally identify as left in the
united states which is um
you know
personal
uh kind of individual freedom including
sexual freedom freedom to do what you
want to do with your body um
opposition to the war on drugs
opposition to the um
overwhelming size and scope of our
criminal justice apparatus like those
all seem like good places to start um
but then i actually think like in some
ways the way to go is to just rip off
the band-aid on the places where we
really typically disagree with the left
and to say
you know i know that you are skeptical
of capitalism and markets but let me
tell you why i think they helped the
poor
like i i know that in some ways like
that is an argument that people should
have heard but i genuinely think that
maybe they haven't yet and to have it
come from someone that they know or
trust um
can really be useful um and then we
actually have a piece uh in the upcoming
issue by jacob sullem uh which is about
gun control and about how if you oppose
the war on drugs because at least in
part because you think it has racially
disparate outcomes and has origins in
racist ideology then you should also
oppose gun control for those same
reasons uh and i think like the two
boogeymen of libertarianism for the left
are guns and capitalism so just like get
get in there and try to talk about it in
language that people on the left
i also i think pistol whipping them
with your gun
that your second amendment approved gun
is also a pretty convincing argument or
uh would be going to work with the
blackjack what uh a blackjack is nice
that in many states they're not
regulated yeah um a sap yeah um i would
also uh think it's it's worth pointing
out you know libertarianism or classical
liberalism 19th century 18th 19th
century liberalism is the original
liberal position and as catherine was
talking about it was a shift of power
from you know power you know hierarchy
authoritarian tyrannical powers
inherited powers to people things being
devolved to the individual and it's
worth understanding that free market
economics or capitalism is the economic
application of that principle to one
sphere of human activity but it's not
the overwhelming one but liberals and
leftists and this is more true and is
going to become more and more true over
the coming years are very distinct
beasts
most liberals most democrats if you
think about somebody like a bill clinton
or even a hillary clinton circa 2000
they agreed that markets were really
good at producing more stuff and
delivering more stuff to more people
they are not bernie sanders leftists who
hate capitalism we hate markets who ate
prices who ate entrepreneurs and stuff
like that so we actually
have so much in common with liberals to
say you know what like amazon is pretty
[ __ ] great and wasn't it better to
have it during the pandemic than not
we shouldn't be throwing that out as
well as then talk about various kinds of
social issues and and that idea that you
know what the best world is where
individuals can get along peacefully
with each other and libertarianism i
think and liberalism properly understood
provides that scaffolding it's you know
it's the operating system for a society
where lots of people can run their
personal life applications without
crashing the system that's the goal
let's kind of focus on that you know
what's one thing this person could do
they could donate a hundred dollars to
reasons webathon that we're having right
now and you get a free digital
subscription and maybe they could give
that subscription to their friends i
mean uh doing the uh yeah doing the the
frenemy subscription is uh yeah it's
right always uh very important uh
superman do you have anything to add to
that i would just add that the way that
uh one of the ways that reason uh
engages with uh liberalism and even with
the left uh i i think is just through
our coverage in particular of criminal
justice and police abuse and we hit that
note every single day and uh every
single week and that is something that
we do specifically just to sort of
remind people that we are that we are
opposed to state power in all of its
forms and i do relish the grudging
tweets that we get sometimes from people
about it like on the regular we will get
a tweet that's like say what you want
about the mean adjective mean adjective
mean adjective mean adjective people at
reason
they are consistent on
police abuse criminal justice whatever
like th that means more to me than the
people who agree with us generally those
people who hate it that we do this well
i think that also gets the the
distinction between liberals and
progressives and i i when i joined
reason in 93 this was like a big bugaboo
of mine and it's just gotten worse
liberals don't really care about
criminal justice that much i'm not
saying they should but they don't really
care you know whereas like people on the
left really care about that kind of
stuff and i think liberals the sweet
spot is going to be more things like you
know you look at the way markets work
you know because they tend to be
friendly to markets they're not they're
not inimical and then you kind of show
that capitalism is regulating itself
pretty well and it actually needs less
regulation than you think
and if you believe in things like free
speech because liberals are opposed to
identity politics progressives are going
in that direction there's there's a lot
of good overlap there um let's go to a
round of individualized
questions peter can i before we do that
could i get a splash of your freedom
press coffee thank you oh that maybe i
want some of that too uh on a coffee
break as we're not breaking
we're going this is live man you know
and it's folger's crystals that's what
you're telling me you're soaking in it
yeah okay um
this comes to dr nick gillespie from uh
michael mermack from michaelson what a
false name
it's just made up it sounds made up the
question below uh is for primary for dr
nick gillespie uh many cultures have
national epics literary compositions
that illustrate the sense of life and
typical character of a people for
example iranians have the book of kings
shaname and estonians have kaylie's son
and i'm not going to pronounce that word
uh number one as a doctor of literature
does the u.s have a national epic that
sums up the individualist or libertarian
character of americans you cannot
mention to tocqueville yeah uh number
two can the rest wouldn't want to well
the rest of the panel we don't need that
yeah let's hear let's hear nick okay
yeah so what i wouldn't uh mention
tocqueville he's you know the most
overrated figure in american letters
absolutely democracy in america is kind
of interesting but uh you know what
just like uh bernard henry
edition bernard henry levy you know like
french people know and represent you
know they understand very little about
america and when they come here they're
almost always wrong having said that i
my personal take on this kind of stuff
is that
the literary genre that kind of defines
america for a variety of reasons is the
autobiography or the memoir and it's
partly because it's individualistic by
nature uh and i would say that the books
of my are the books to me that i go back
to on a regular basis that really i find
fascinating and and kind of tell they're
the dna of a lot of things in america
are the captivity narrow narrative of
mary rowlandson who is a
colonial settler who was captured by
indians and then has a bunch of weird
and interesting adventures and she's
writing for an english audience during
an english civil war
fantastic and that actually is one of
the first great works that was written
or or experienced in america although it
was published in london the
autobiography of ben franklin uh which
is just a phenomenally complicated he's
not a saint by any stretch but he his
whole thing is he's writing to his son
who would later become the last colonial
governor of new jersey who he would be
estranged from because of the revolution
and he said i want to show you how i
made my way in the world and it's like
the first how-to book and it's about an
individual
getting on his way and it's it's just
deep and wonderful and then in that uh
in in that frame of uh kind of genre
whatever the autobiographies of
frederick douglass there's three three
versions of them but again he has in
that line i choke up thinking about it
uh you have seen you know you have seen
how i was made a slave uh now i will
tell you how how i would i made uh how i
became a man um and that is another
great work of
um self-creation self-innovation it's
warm it's empathic it's deeply moving
and it's also fundamentally about
capitalism his move from a slave economy
to a free labor economy in the north is
one of the great moments in that book
and it's also one that current
champions of frederick douglass and
identity politics in the 1619 project
always have to explain away and in my uh
my doctoral dissertation i treated uh
douglas a bit there were critics and
this was in the late 80s early 90s when
you know when late capitalism was first
becoming a real thing right because
people thought the soviet union was
going to win
but people would be like you know it is
a shame that douglas for all of his
wisdom and insight that he didn't
understand when he left the south and
moved to the north and became like a
ship cocker in massachusetts that he was
merely trading one form of slavery
for another meaning making money and
keeping it for the work that you do so
those books are great the other thing
that i would say and we we talked about
this in the 35
35th anniversary
issue of reason where we had 35 years of
freedom uh the little house books are a
fantastic they're in a bad odor now
because they were canceled because of
some passages that were dubbed you know
negative or disparaging towards native
americans which is a misinterpretation
of the book but that series is an
incredible
counter
kind of revisionist way of talking about
how america was settled which is by
families not by weirdo rugged
individualist mountain men like you know
natty bumpo who go out and you know tame
the wilderness and then we follow it's
so i would say those those things are
the things i look towards can i can i
make a suggestion here um that's not a
book and uh not an autobiography of any
kind but in fact
the marvel cinematic universe and i am
not kidding here i'm not kidding at all
these are they're these are all stories
of self-formation um right they're about
it starts it out being about
billionaires and nerds and inventors and
scientists and soldiers and eventually
it becomes also about women and
minorities and immigrants and people
from other freaking planets and crazy
raccoons and just all of the kind of
deep weirdness of humanity and even the
things that are that are extra human
right and it is it is about uh it's
about people who become heroic
individuals and who are constantly
struggling both to be good and to be
themselves because that is the same
struggle and that seems to me in some
ways like the american struggle oh my
god that's not bad i i'm halfway there
with i thought you were going to say the
godfather i think frederick douglass
just put you in like an in like a
empathetic mood yeah frederick douglass
is uh you know he's definitely a
superhero but uh the one that people
aren't that familiar with is the
captivity narrative mary rollinson and
it's really it's
it's freaking awesome
so this is directed at catherine um
so this comes from sorry uh john buck
his name is one of my best baseball
coaches by the way john buck it's
probably not the same person um though
magazine with libertarian leanings could
never become as ineffective and as
useless as the fda
an outsider might get the impression
reason's very own bureaucratic structure
you firing shots here john buck uh isn't
as forward thinking as they could be
sure your writers and thinkers as
opposed to business people but the
wonderful thing about capitalism is
those who think outside the box will
normally be rewarded and kind he's
getting around to the question i swear
let's see we have a monthly print and
easing edition of reason a youtube
channel as well as roundtable interview
and soho form debate podcast that
produce on average one show per week all
trendlines point to digital growth why
not produce a daily
roundtable podcast with panels comprised
of other writers on the staff a few of
whom already do fill in work when
vacations are taken the more content you
provide means the more ads that can be
placed more ads placed the more revenue
you have coming in
i'm not going to hold my breath for a
reason streaming channel still a great
idea uh but the point still stands the
more content you put out there the more
people you reach catherine what do you
say about that uh you're right and you
know i think this is a great time to
remind everyone who is watching or
listening to this podcast that to
support more great reason content they
should donate to our webathon do we have
anything that we'd like to sort of tease
to the
the the webathon donors and listeners
and viewers and readers of recent
content about stuff that we're going to
be producing in the future yeah so we in
fact are going to be uh growing some of
our um our podcast offerings so you can
take credit for this john buck you can
say that this was all your idea um but
we are we are hopefully going to be
debuting a few new pods in the next year
or so
uh you can of course also get a little
more reason content on your instagrams
and your twitters uh where we have been
putting more stuff
and uh we're doing dance-offs on tickets
saying that tick-tock is a thing but
maybe tick-tock is a thing so uh yes
more reason content coming your way and
again i love that no no
okay so we're not doing tick-tock it
seems i love that
seizure people continue to really
believe that like advertising revenue is
a big part of our
budget and it is it does matter but the
thing that actually matters is donations
yes um deductibles
deductible donations to our 501c3 three
i don't know why i blanked that the
other day uh this one goes to scooterman
who i understand
uh has a bonus uh newsletter about
cocktails so this would seem appropriate
uh david denver thanks in part to your
excellent article how government killed
the cocktail yes that was an excellent
art along with the discovery of bars
like the dead rabbit in new york and
death enco in my hometown of denver i
become pretty particular when it comes
to my drinking says david do you peter
suterman have an approach to deciding if
ordering a cocktail at a particular
establishment will be worth it i find
that diamonds in the rough seem to be
few and far between and premium prices
rarely mean premium cocktails so i
rarely take the gamble anymore if i
haven't done prior research i was
curious if there are things you look for
at an establishment to see if their
cocktails may be worth trying yeah so
that is uh you have already discovered
the first thing that you discover about
like uh expensive cocktails is that the
fact that they are expensive does not
make them good neither does weird
ingredients or like goofy looking you
know whole forest garnishes even if
somebody has spent a whole lot of time
like constructing an elaborate you know
a whole new rainforest to solve global
warming on top of your drink that does
not make the underlying cocktail good um
so i think that the the most important
thing is to do research and to become
familiar with the bars that are highly
regarded in any city that you happen to
be going to death and company in denver
is of course a great bar
death and company in new york is my
favorite bar in the world i've learned a
lot from them and from their books but i
would say that if you don't know in
advance
the two things that you can look for are
crafts how the which is just to say how
are the bartenders putting together the
drinks are they measuring precisely are
they stirring in a way that seems to be
consistent uh shaking in a way that is
consistent are they shaking more than
just sort of uh one lazy
shake right like catherine occasionally
asks me to analyze a shake at a bar and
i will like deliver like a paragraph
review of the bartender's shake and what
it tells you about the likely quality of
the cocktails this is a thing that you
can learn to do especially if you've
learned to make these drinks on your own
the other thing that you can look for is
is the bar conversant in the classics uh
so do they have manhattans on the menu
order one is it any good if they can't
make a good manhattan or a good
old-fashioned or a good martini whatever
your choice of classic is uh then they
are not going to be able to make other
cocktails well but at that point you've
already spent so do you beat the check
do you run out or do you fake a heart
attack or take a call outside
on the bar and you know you sometimes
you uh you take the loss sometimes i
just see superman like quietly drinking
a beer in a bar and that is like the
sickest burn
like it's just like if you're in a bar
that has a cocktail menu and the
cocktails have like names and stuff and
suderman is like just holding a beer
ouch
option i look for bartenders who can uh
make cocktails by throwing bottles high
up into the air like tom cruise and
cocktail while doing the hippie hippie
shake yeah are they are they dancing on
the bar because that is exactly quality
yeah let's go to some libertarian red
meat questions matt b from college
station texas right yeah um i lived uh
fairly close to college station when i
lived in huntsville texas uh home of the
sam houston state bearcats
the death factory yeah uh
is the free state project all it is
advertised to be katherine and why isn't
it more of a mainstream libertarian
talking point
so i think the free state project in
some ways is what it was advertised to
be i think people wanted more from it
than what it was advertised to be if
that makes sense so um i
did not sign on to the free state
project again see previous comments
about hating to be cold but um
i have gone to pork fest which is their
kind of annual
uh festival gathering whatever um and it
is delightful like just a bunch of like
weirdos in skirts with like their ar15
selling you drugs like it's just what
you imagine it's just incredible all
background characters from a guardians
of the galaxy film 100
and um
and so in that sense i think like
building that community has been a
success um it was all there was always
going to be very high attrition for
those who don't know the free state
project's idea was that people signed a
pledge that once a certain threshold was
reached they would all move to new
hampshire and kind of take over
uh whatever amount of the government
there they could and make a libertarian
utopia um that has not happened but i do
think um you can see among other things
in the backlash
from normies in like keene and other
places there that they have had some
success um and uh i think i actually
originally learned this from brian
doherty that people um go around feeding
the parking meters to prevent the
government from getting parking to get
money like that's like a cultural norm
in some places in new hampshire so you
know maybe it's just that i have
um modest ambitions for any project that
seeks to fix things via government
mechanisms i think that those very very
rarely work in any form but um but the
free state project you know it's
actually i think it's similar to
um crypto similar to bitcoin in that is
just an idea that someone had and wrote
a paper about that did become a thing in
the world and so i give them credit for
that yeah that is cool there's always
going to be i mean the
number of libertarians uh in the in the
country is it's hard depends on how you
measure it sometimes sort of five
percent 15 whatever um
uh but the number of people who
as libertarians enough to move to know
new hampshire it's not going to be
a million people um so it's just one of
many things and it's nice we're friendly
um let's take this one to nick this
comes from jim from brooklyn
uh hello crew let's talk 2024
presidential elections
let's so he's an optimist
let's suppose
that the dems go with either biden or
harris the republicans go once again
with trump and the libertarians nominate
justin amash in that scenario what do
you think are the odds for a stunning or
not very stunning libertarian victory
what other scenarios do you envision in
2024 that could put the lp in position
as true contenders for the top job or
any other political jobs that rank
higher than say becoming a constable in
pennsylvania or the odds there could be
some kind of republican breakup between
trumpies and more liberty oriented
non-trumpies and what would that mean
for the lp i uh you know i'm being
serious about this for a minute i would
put if it's a mosh versus biden versus
trump i would say you know the chances
of him winning are between 95 and 99
yeah
uh he would be fantastic i think he is
from a political perspective he is the
absolute best person who has been
involved in libertarian politics ever um
and this is not to short uh short uh
sheet uh people like gary johnson uh
people like ed clark people like harry
brown whatever you know whoever you want
to talk about ron paul certainly um but
amash is the real package for any number
of reasons i think if if if that's this
if that's the scenario i think it's
highly likely that a libertarian
candidate with a well-run presidential
run would get 10
easily because the
the lack of interest in trump and the
lack of support for biden is large and
growing these are old men who represent
two worn out shitty ideals of what
politics can do what the republican
party of the democratic party can do i
hope that they face off again because
this is you know it will be the third
time at least the third time in a row
where the parties are saying please kill
us
um and i think but what what has to go
along with that because you know what
matt you and i obviously have written
about this at length and whatnot what
has to go along with it is a positive
vision of what a libertarian form of
government at the national level would
look like and i think amash brings that
because it's based on autonomy it's
based on empathy it's based on real you
know on actually constraining the size
scope and spending of government
according to principles that we've all
agreed to you know at various points in
our history um and i would love and and
amash looks like the future of america
he's the son of immigrants he's he's
multi-ethnic uh he is both religious and
fiercely um you know non-traditional in
the way that he goes about things and
he's mostly
interested you know go back to what
peter was talking about earlier he's
interested you know that government
should help the people who need help
they don't have to help the rest of us
if we're doing okay
we can get on with our lives and we
should pay less in taxes and be
regulated less and then we can funnel
real meaningful help to people so i
think it would be fantastic i don't have
any sense of whether or not amash is
going to run i don't know if you guys
have he's kind of gone dark
uh you know in terms of a lot of his
ambitions like spiritually or i i wish i
wish no yeah he i mean he just he hasn't
been talking or it hasn't been as public
about this kind of stuff and there is a
real
uh civil war going on in the libertarian
party which needs it because the
libertarian party has not been you know
for a party that's been around for 50
years it's kind of going sideways for a
while so you know there's the mises
caucus people there's people like amash
there's more traditional type uh people
you know like something has to happen
and i hope that amash emerges as a as a
viable third party candidate for the
libertarian party i will agree with you
that if it is biden versus trump versus
amash
that uh that is uh the maximalist
position i think for the libertarian
party because people don't like trump
except for the people who do and i don't
know if anyone actually likes biden
anymore but no there's you know they're
like against a third and a third you
know that are that are diehards for
these idiots and that and that
translates into you know 45 49 for each
of them in an election
unless there's somebody like justin
amash who is really
energetic powerful thoughtful
ideologically you know oriented towards
the future i i think the chances of that
being the three-way race are not very
high um even though trump has still a
lot of sway in the party i think there
will be a genuine contest i think
democrats are already like oh boy but
they haven't the democrats also have to
get rid of two people because there's
two dead bodies in the in the white
house right now or right in washington
there's him and harris and nobody is no
but nobody in the democratic party who
wants to win the 2024 election is like
yeah we got to go with harris uh it's
not happening um let us go speaking of
justin amash and science fiction
were we we weren't but uh i was thinking
about it i will say that the scenario in
which the libertarian party wins a
presidential election is indeed science
fiction
amash and his brother are uh absolutely
ridiculous star trek nerds yeah i think
it's next generation is there jam i
don't know what that means um
but one that came out in the 1980s and
starred my captain john luke picard okay
well so here's a question from it's not
even american faithful listener and
correspondent leonard goodnights
if that is your real name again these
people come up with better pseudonyms um
uh if the roundtablers were a star trek
bridge crew
who would hold what positions
and what species would you all be
obviously peter has to answer this
question uh so i'll start with myself um
just because i've been thinking about
this did you i
did you feel the weight of like the wind
that like the preparation and that like
let's look at the notes over there yeah
i blacked out because the oxygen left
the room do it go ahead so as for myself
like in some ways i feel like i'm kind
of like riker right like sort of takes
orders grows a beard in the middle of
like you know season four uh sometimes
shows up with a trombone like oh okay
right but i also feel a lot on this
podcast at least like jordy leforch and
of course
maybe maybe more than that i feel like
levar burton reading the scripts that
were handed him because i don't know if
you guys know this about how star trek
the next generation script were written
we don't yes but
there was a lot of like techno babble on
this show right the tachyon emitters
were always out of phase except the
writers wouldn't write the tachyon
emitters are out of phase they would
just write two brackets and then the
word tech in between them and the
science advisor would have to come in
and fill in like no it's attack
animators again of course right and i
feel like my role on this podcast is
often just like matt you're like peter
tech
so so i i kind of feel like jordy
leforce who was the who was the guy with
the horseshoe crab on his forehead
wharf thank you you mean the cling so i
don't know who the klingon is here um
but i do klingon is our audio producer
yeah oh that's that's actually
absolutely correct who promised me a can
of tactical bacon if i said that on this
podcast i will be collecting what is
tactical i don't know
you don't open it open it in a field by
yourself okay just don't open it in the
bacon that's a weapon or it's bacon that
can be used after all the weapons are
out of bullets and either way it's great
so um i think uh nick actually here is
cute he's he's not a member of the main
cast he is simply the most interesting
um uh supporting character who comes
to the who he like shows up on the
bridge he's a godlike uh alien being who
shows up on the bridge in to like taunt
the captain um and also make some really
good points at the same time uh and wear
goofy costumes and sometimes there's a
mariachi band involved uh it's always
wonderful when john delancey shows up i
think matt welch here is not from the
next generation but matt welch is from
the original series and you are doctor
mccoy
you are bones you are crossbones yeah
crack my knuckles and jump for jewels
you are you you've you've got that sort
of i'm not that cranky you're you've got
that that cranky exasperated vibe but
you also like are you crucial
he's kirk he's he's he's a hundred
percent [ __ ] i'm not making out with
everybody no and i think i think here we
have uh we have both kirk and picard in
the form of captain award but not the
lady captain nobody likes the lady
captain island i don't know why yeah
because she's a lady we probably the
sexism um no we previously explored this
question y'all may remember um when
freedom fest was star trek themed
and there was a brief period where we
seriously considered acquiring
star trek costumes appearing on stage as
are as various characters it luckily
that did not occur and i think we can
all yeah that was for the best you're i
uh i want to make a pitch he's not on
the bridge in any of the shows but the
gorn i want to be the gorn
you know the gorn is this lizard type
creature that basically spends half an
episode getting pelted by large
styrofoam boulders by william shatner in
the san fernando valley in the great
fight scene ever filmed you should just
google it star trek gorn fight scene
yeah he so kirk has a move in which he
balls his two hands into like a rock
over his head and tries to smash the
gordon's head and you're like that's not
fighting that's i don't know what that
is but it doesn't like but it worked it
ultimately works 70s fight yeah tv
he does something similar with khan as
well but uh the fight scene with between
corn and kirk also eerily anticipates uh
muhammad ali versus george foreman
uh it's it's almost the same it's almost
you know uh
step by step it's it's it's a complete
ripoff she's not here today but she is a
recurring guest on this podcast so i
will just say that stephanie slate is
obviously spock
obviously um since we already started
this and since i know at least
one of us have spent a lot of time maybe
all for uh rehearsing uh or researching
this question this comes from molly uh
what three
fictional characters describe you three
nick you obviously come up with that
i really i was totally stymied by this
and i had a quick confab
with people i used to respect yeah just
before this podcast
yeah well like i said matt i you know i
used to respect okay so maybe i still
respect you or maybe i never respect
yeah
either way so i don't have any good
answers for this i did one of the uh uh
game of thrones quizzes that catherine
suggested that we look at and i turned
out to be of course peter dinklage yeah
from game of thrones and i think that's
a pretty tight fit i have been likened
to uh you know the fonzie i'm the free
market fonzie i feel like that
especially because i jumped the shark
sometime in the early 80s when the happy
days crew was running a dude farm out in
a dude ranch out in california
to be a little bit more
uh pompous i like to one of my favorite
characters
yeah thank you uh
in
in literature is the uh hickey character
in the eugene o'neill the iceman cometh
because uh it's set in a bar i think
i've mentioned this because donald trump
i figured as a hickey character set in a
bar where there's a bunch of bar flies
who are all sitting around just drinking
all the time talking about how when
things get right they're going to do all
of these incredible dreams and this
traveling salesman named hickey who was
originally played by jason robards jr
comes in
and he disabuses them the play which is
about 10 hours long he just
spends time destroying each of their
dreams by saying like you're never going
to do that and et cetera and then he is
revealed and because the play is you
know 100 years old i feel safe ruining
it for people but then it is revealed at
the end that hickey who is himself a
major busan has murdered his wife and
maybe a couple of other people and get
and gets hauled off and so exit the
scene and i have a lot of empathy for
hickey i like the way that he
you know he forces people to be
realistic about themselves hopefully you
can do that in a way that actually
empowers people to do their dreams and
then he's revealed as you know a uh as
bad as the rest of them actually works
this folds in with my uh obvious go-to
with nick is that he's the
no country for old men yeah anton
yeah uh catherine what are your answers
to this question another agent of chaos
like you
yeah uh so the reason staff a while back
took the like an online what fictional
character are you quiz like collectively
this is um my greatest temptation as a
manager i would make people take yeah
like all manner of personality tests
except for that i recognize that they
would admire
any of them like i just love that stuff
even though it's your enneagram mostly
[ __ ] and um i which nazi from
hogan's heroes are not the buzzfeed ones
the pseudo-scientific ones that's my jam
and um on this on this quiz i do come up
as um olena tyrell which you all may
remember from game of thrones as the old
lady who in the end says like i want her
to know it was me like the real that's
diana rick the mean um mastermind old
lady which feels right to me um other
results on this quiz that i got include
uh hermione granger sorry to say but
that's just the truth
and uh mycroft homes sherlock holmes is
smarter brother who's smarter
he prefers to work from the chair he
doesn't like to do the legwork
and is perhaps the british government
and then also
every lady ceo in all of tv like you
name them they came up in my top ten
like and it's it's you know what who are
the lady ceo it is what it is uh like we
got the shiv roys oh yeah out now that's
the charlotte hail from westworld
yeah yeah that's pretty good all of the
sort of sinister lady ceos uh in the
marvel universe
my thank you
i'll kill you yeah um look you could see
him sweating while he's saying that i
get i'm running down bhl
dr strange is the is the marvel universe
result that i get are you a secret
watcher you're lady loki we've we've
covered that i'm just saying that's not
what showed up i think you should go
deep on the whole diana rig her
character because like from
my star trek result which i don't know
what it means is uh jedsia dex
so jedsia dex is uh
oh yeah yeah
dax is uh a uh like a host parasite
situation in which like a little worm
thing goes into a new body every like 80
or 90 years and sometimes the worm thing
goes into a man and sometimes it goes
into a woman but it's like it could be
either at any point is sort of the point
here and there's a
and there's sort of a duality to it
because the host also changes the
personality each time and she's got
super cool neck tattoos
i think matt you as a star trek person
you are charlie x
peter do you remember who charlie x is
from the original series wait is that
the one who turned out to be uh jack the
ripper no
no no charlie x is a uh is an uh a man
who is actually has the mind of a child
and then gets very angry
all the time and like one famous scene
it's the only reason to watch the
original series to be quite honest
is he he uh gets mad at a woman
at a woman uh you know in a blue
mini dress i think and she turns around
and she doesn't have a face anymore
reminder he doesn't she doesn't have a
face the reason why she gets
out
he gets pulled out by his donate to
reason
speaking of cool neck tattoos if you
give us 50 dollars robert walker you're
junior
that's 50 you get a temporary tattoo
with the reason logo and it's pretty
cool so you you could i'll just say that
charlie x is better than malcolm x but
they're both revolutionary uh i want to
cast matt and nick as zafud brebelbrox
from uh
galaxy how dare you kind of uh like he's
a two-headed con man who is
occasionally the president of the galaxy
usually very much feel like the trillion
dear zaphodz sometimes guys i don't know
what these people are talking about but
you do like the thing with two heads
right by a rosie greer uh raymo land
movie from the early 70s guys come on
get it together
rosie greer taught us one important
thing in life and that it's all right to
cry peter you have 10 seconds to say
which three characters you are in my top
character on that quiz that everybody
took was varys from game of thrones who
uh i'll just let you all figure out what
you think of that um i would just note
that the top like top 10 character
across the reason staff was ian malcolm
from jurassic park and i really think
that's accurate like there is a huge
amount of ian malcolm dna in the reasons
which who is he life that's the job
jeff goldblum character yeah yeah yeah
sure the rock star scientist yeah yeah
who's working it out in like real time
speaks in jazz yeah i uh obviously
identify the most in the world of
fiction with the dude from the big
lebowski like it's it's always been an
aspirational situation with me
fashion and
uh and musical taste um and but i took
the the dumb quiz and i turned out to be
uh uh remy from ratatouille yes oh my
god
is that the rat or the guy
because he wants to be his [ __ ] all he
wants to do is be a chef well he has a
dream yeah
great at his at his craft and also he
likes french ladies no and he's a rat um
all right let's uh
let's try to get some quick policy under
the
deadline here now that we've covered the
good stuff uh my question is this
following the george floyd protests and
blm movement in 2020 there was a moment
where criminal justice and policing
reform seemed imminent has that moment
been snuffed out for good or
is it closer to a matt welch mixed
metaphor where the flame still burns on
a twisted ocean of rocky shores
um i don't see the problem with that
specifically what could end qualified
immunity one of the worst presidents in
our uh criminal justice system catherine
uh i am a little pessimistic at the
moment but i think that um
this is probably hopefully this is the
sort of thing that um
the idea has been planted the seed isn't
planted in the rocky shores
and it's winter now but the seed will
bloom again in the spring when
conditions are better and so maybe this
is we've sort of made some steps in the
right direction
uh across the ocean of despair most of
the stuff happens locally
most new administrations work on their
big one
two or three things at the beginning and
that's all they pay attention to when
all those stop
um then maybe they'll pay more attention
federally and hopefully they will get
this is also a good i mean qualified
immunity should go obviously uh police
union should be
broken in various ways but this is also
a good example of where
custom is more important than law the
laws on the books will take forever to
change but i think police are acting
more circumspectly and people are
demanding more and that you know we we
are seeing a difference in the way that
people go about their business because
of all of the attention that's been
called to this um all right uh this
question is very important comes from
joseph hinshaw um what's your favorite
reason rat joke i should say at reason
rad it's a twitter account and what's
the story behind it
um there there is no such thing as a
reason rat joke they are all just
real things that were said by a reason
staffer
occasionally it's slacked or slacked by
a recent staffer um the uh the account
is manned by uh by an anonymous person
we do not know who the reason rat is has
there been an attempt to smoke probably
but it's the reason rats
anonymity remains secure um but you can
follow it on twitter
and hear the nonsense things that we say
they are mostly just like delightfully
out of context
quotes um but the the story behind it is
that our office
was infested with rats and it still is a
little and if that's not a reason to
donate
to the webathon
i really don't know what is uh we are in
dupont circle in washington dc we have a
very cool historic building and man
we got rats we got a lot of rats um
including one that was once discovered
inside our coffee maker please
yeah yeah that was
that was the ultimate there's a reason
some of us work in new york city oh yeah
you know
right
yeah
you you literally
came up with remy on your test results
don't be
don't be snippy you're so self-hating uh
this one probably can be bounced between
uh peter and catherine although i'm sure
nick has things to say as well from
aaron would you recommend any writers or
other resources for analyzing science
fiction
through a libertarian lens i love to
hear from y'all how asimov's foundation
novels which i've learned since i was a
teen reflect the monstrous technocratic
borderline totalitarian view of the
world and i want to hear more
uh can we talk about asthma for a minute
peter yes yeah i know asking you that
was like that means you need to keep it
short
i'm just saying for a minute because you
guys will talk for hours we'll talk for
hours um i
uh i actually think it is true that
asimov's vision is monstrous and
totalizing but that it is not it does
not present that sort of totalitarian
world as um a pure utopia that a lot of
his stories are about the ways that um
centralizing and automating things that
were once human and messy uh had will
not totally work out
my favorite isaac asimov short story
which i think i've talked about before
is called franchise and it's um was
probably inspired by the fact that the
um famous real computer univac correctly
predicted the um 1952 presidential
election and so asimov wrote a short
story about future elections in which a
single human is brought in
sort of asked a bunch of questions just
to build in human irrationality uh to
the result and then multivac um
it was azimov's kind of supercomputer um
determines the outcome of the election
and i think that like that to 13 year
old me blew my mind like immediately
explains a lot about politics probably
there's a straight line from that story
to my views that you should not vote
today
um and uh
and it's a classic asimov in that it's
it's
it is monstrous and totalitarian but it
also shows
the ways in which that world
misses the mark or sort of you know has
has a hole at the center of it
um in terms of resources i would just
say libertarian future society which um
gives out prometheus awards every year a
great way to just like
build up your libertarian science
fiction reading list i would just say
read biographies of your uh favorite
writers because the biographies even if
they are critical even if they are not
focused on the writers politics they
will inevitably cover some of those
political influences and the uh
fractious political nature of writing
science fiction in the uh
in the 1900s in the united states
because all of those folks were involved
in
science fiction political societies or
political societies that became science
fiction societies or science fiction
groups that that broke up and fractured
and became multiple other groups because
of politics and so just understanding
the history there and the kind of milieu
that they were involved in is really
important to understanding their
politics and how to think about them
through the lens of politics yeah i
would say uh following up on that by uh
there's some biographies of robert
heinlein who is great and heinlein in a
lot of ways uh brian dougherty 10 15
years ago wrote a great piece on the
100th birthday of of hindland heinlein
is kind of the spirit animal of reason
as much as iran might have been because
he is you know at the beginning of the
60s he was both a militarist as well as
a free love advocate he was a you know
an aquarian and a uh and uh you know
what warhawk
and that is
you know that's a powerful uh vibe
throughout uh modern libertarianism you
can understand a huge amount about
reasons worldview just by reading
stranger in a strange land and the moon
is a harsh mistress which strange trench
lamb was the topic of my high school uh
uh thesis uh essay
high school thesis yeah in english
high school yeah what is that well you
just suppose
was that a three-page paper it was uh i
showed you was it a five paragraph essay
it's called the martian and the hippies
and it was about uh how stranger in the
strange land uh informed and predicted
the summer of love in 1967 wow it's all
about the diggers do you still have that
i do yeah i do the writing is uh is
subpar but the thinking is outstanding
yeah um
is it handwritten or typewritten
what kind of margins you got on that um
actually i i don't i can't i can't
recall that exactly included as a pdf uh
my mind as an nft my
stepfather uh mike townsend who's
probably not listening to this but i
hope that he is um uh he came into my
life when i was around 12 and like it's
like he had two big gambits like one was
the the iron ran gambit the other was
the robert heinlein
and the iron man boy that didn't stick
but uh i wouldn't get into the heinous
that was uh that was helpful um let's
take this more like for me and nick for
reasons that'll easily become obvious
from philip with all due apologies to
certain members of the round table i'd
like to ask a sports question
i love the free markets which have you
guys do you guys wanna take five yeah
yeah yeah yeah
look right actually let's only use that
camera
to show them and it should have the same
thing actually if people do ask me about
they're like
when you say like uh oh what what is it
like to make the podcast they always
specifically ask like what are you doing
while nick and matt are talking nonsense
i imagine it's like when chang and ang
the siamese twins when you know they
were both married and when one of them
would have sex the other one would kind
of go into a twilight zone and not
really
that's what i'm assuming you guys do
when we talk about by that comparison
i'm sorry i should have called them
conjoined twins yeah thank you
thank you i apologize
um
moving on uh i'd love for you guys i
love the free markets which have given
us so many wonderful things but i
instinctively bulk
at extending this love to the concept of
paying
college athletes i'm not opposed to
paying them all together but my brain
immediately wants to condition it with
gasps wage ceilings and floors heavy
regulation of recruiting practices
sponsorships and donor involvement and
other authoritarian seeming limits that
would absolutely horrify me if applied
to any other economic activity i realize
the reasons i think these things would
be necessary in college sports are the
same reasons that socialists think they
are necessary everywhere protect
competition level the playing field
limit the power of the wealthy empower
small business
in this case small schools etc and that
scares me do the challenges of college
sports and athlete labor actually make a
broader case for socialism dr nick am i
wrong to think strict controls would be
necessary to pay college athletes while
still keeping their sports fair or do
college sports and broader economics
legitimately call for different
solutions
one i would not argue that uh you know
whatever happens in college football
thence the universe like these two
things you don't have to leap from one
to the other uh college sports and
different divisions could be
laboratories of democracy
of economic democracy and things like
that but
i and i also don't understand how it's
better to have them in a form of peonage
now where they really don't i mean
there's some of the likeness you know
where ncaa athletes can can get some
money if they're popular based on their
likeness or their schools can
that comes back to them somehow like
giving them some money would be worse
than giving them no money which is the
status quo and the cesco is also it has
been super heavily regulated there's all
these arcane rules that the ncaa does to
to maintain the illusion that there
aren't uh incentives from outside donors
and money polluting the system the money
yeah and more broadly you know let's say
that the ncaa which is a monopoly and
there's uh there's a great book that was
written by the olympic marathoner turned
fantastic sports journalist kenny moore
about bill bauer it's called bill
bowerman and the uh the men of oregon he
was the oregon track coach when steve
prefontaine was there you know dozens of
olympians world champions etc
um
what what was great about that book is
it actually shows how the ncaa squeezed
out the aau in the 60s and it's it's
fascinating but having said all of that
because these guys are starting to go to
sleep and cobwebs are forming on them um
all sorts of sub markets have rules uh
you know so major league baseball apart
from you know the government granted
monopoly on certain things or football
you can come up with a league where you
say okay we're going to have a bunch of
rules the new york stock exchange has
rules and things like that so there's
nothing wrong with a league or a group
of people can you know coming together
to do a certain activity setting rules
on compensation that implies that the
whole world should be run by a socialist
you know covenant uh based in zurich or
something like that i think it would be
good if athletes were more directly
compensated for their labor
i also think it would be great and i say
this as somebody who really was pissed
when michigan finally beat ohio state
for the first time in 11 years on sunday
i followed college football pretty
religiously
i think it would be great if colleges
got rid of their sports teams or or gave
the naming rights to autonomous
organizations put them on the blockchain
make them daos or something like that
but get sports out of college having
said that it'd be it'd be great to see
athletes actually being compensated yeah
they create value they should get paid
um and uh and that should be fine and
the supreme court the unanimous decision
this year um uh laughed at these puny uh
kind of uh arguments the the the you
know about the pristine nature of
amateur athletics and all that kind of
stuff like stop it um we're getting
close to the end i want to get on at
least one more round of individualized
um things here this to suiterman from
steve schatz from new york
nick come on uh what video game or video
game series is the most libertarian
both thematically and actual gameplay
oh man obviously the bethesda rpgs in
particular fallout 3 fallout 4 and elder
scrolls uh skyrim
elder scroll skyrim in particular i
would just uh say is um
it's a it's a game about individual
choice and so after a very short kind of
tutorial introduction sequence you can
do anything go anywhere manipulate
nearly any object in the world in a way
that's really unprecedented in
games that aren't made by by bethesda um
but also the overarching story here
is about a world in which you have some
kind of racist seeming white nord types
who just want to practice their religion
and that's really all they want to do is
be left alone by the uh kind of
imperious kind of
dickish high elves who have taken over
the society and you have to choose
between one of these two camps and the
point is that they're both awful uh and
so like i don't want to say that this is
an explicitly libertarian game made by
libertarians who live just north of
washington dc uh but it is a game made
by a bunch of people who live not too
far from the nation's capital capital
and it is alive to the dumbness and
frustrations of politics as well as like
the glories of of being in a world where
you can choose to do and be anything
um
question to catherine from nathan and
hopefully there's a backstory and
hopefully there's not even uh it says uh
i have a question specifically for kmw
how dare you
wow
spicy nathan i don't i don't know yeah
what does that mean
nevertheless i persisted i i don't know
man how dare i um you know you know what
i do dare maybe it's a like a an
instructional question how dare you yeah
yeah it could be
um
you know what i do dirty i do dare to um
just put in another um
you know plug here for our webathon
there are many ways you can donate if
you donate um a thousand dollars you
could have lunch with one of us
here in the in the dc area if you donate
two thousand dollars you don't have to
yeah those are your two choices um and
um
uh you can also go ahead at this at this
webassign moment and set up monthly
donations that's right occurring a
little money now you could make a
recurring donation it would be great we
would appreciate it and that that money
will allow me
to
well the dare
the monthly option is great i actually
use it and and much of my giving both
the reason and elsewhere because it's
you know it's a little bit at a time
it's a it's a great like if you have to
make the choice every time you're not
going to make the choice even though you
want to make the choice
uh this one to nick from stuart hello
big fan of the show listen every week
that's right stuart thank you is it uh
with an ew or a ua it's an e i'm not
going to answer if the depending on how
the spelling goes ew okay all right um
my question is a few weeks or months ago
nick
made a comment more or less that this
might be the proof that keynesian
economics doesn't work
he didn't elaborate what he meant by
that i'm really curious as to what he
meant by that and what examples he'd
provide i have no idea
what he's talking about but i'll i'll
venture a guess because one of the
things and this goes back to
uh you know we at some point early in
this which to quite honestly feels like
a thousand years ago when we started
this thing
um but today
yeah like this podcast yeah this
particular podcast and i uh um but we
touch on inflation briefly what is
fascinating to me
about what's going on right now is that
everybody in washington and all of the
big wig economists who want to be part
of washington or already are are talking
about this completely as a supply issue
that uh you know what's happened now
that we're all done with covid even
though all the lockdowns are coming back
and all of this kind of [ __ ] they're
saying you know what happened there's so
much pent-up demand and supply hasn't
been able to increase and that's why
there's inflation you know more or
there's more people looking at the same
supply of stuff they keep ignoring the
idea that we have pumped massive amounts
of government money into the system but
through the fed but especially through
uh the treasury through through
borrowing in order to spend all of this
kind of stuff two years ago or in 2019
we were spending 4.5 trillion we've had
two years in a row where we've spent
close to seven trillion dollars and
that's a huge problem what i'm getting
at about the keynesianism stuff is that
we're not having economic growth we have
had a sustained bizarre kind of
experiment in keynesianism where the
government is just pumping more and more
money to you know stimulate demand or to
give people money to buy stuff etcetera
for so long and we have not seen even
going back to the 2008 financial crisis
in the response to that we haven't seen
the kind of economic growth that should
have come along with this type of
consistently overly you know uh targeted
stimulus spending so maybe it's that uh
we're going to be wrapping up here very
shortly thank you for listening and
watching um and for donating reason.com
slash
donate right or slash or slash both of
them
um go there it's fine um i don't know
this would be our closing one it might
be depending on how it's answered
this is from peter not suderman he's
from new york city i've got a life
advice
question for you
how important would you say your
political philosophy is toward your
dating life
i've never dated a libertarian because
there's like three women who consider
themselves libertarians and they all
work at reason but someone's that's not
true um some of them don't work reasons
uh but someone's politics never really
mattered when i met them or dated them
but i imagine there could be some
conflict in the marriage when i have
kids because politics is a reflection of
how you see the world i doubt i could
have a successful relationship with
someone totally woke but maybe i'm wrong
how important is it and since you're all
much older than i uh
i'd like to hear your thoughts and if
you think your answer changed
versus 20 years ago who wants to take
that now
i'll go first because that's happening
um so i actually um i met my husband in
college and we met in a it was there
were no yachts involved
there was one there's one yeah
just one uh okay but mostly it wasn't a
yacht-based relationship and um we met
in a debating society where
we were both on the
libertarian side of a kind of
libertarian anarchist
uh versus traditionalist catholic
conservative um
spectrum where did you go yale yeah all
right all right everyone and um
we how was ross we were fir we were we
were debate allies first and then
friends and then we got together and
then we got married and then we had kids
and it's a very nice story and all this
is to say that that happened so long ago
that i no longer remember what dating
was like but uh it's really great to be
married to someone who agrees with you
politically i think this person is onto
something that like that is a way to um
have a better and easier relationship uh
we still disagree on some stuff but um
the
like disagreeing from shared underlying
values is the best kind of disagreeing
and uh and my marriage has a lot of that
and i recommend it so get yourself a
nice libertarian girl there's tons of us
now i used to get invited to all kinds
of stuff just because like someone
needed a lady on a panel and they're
like so many ladies now i don't i never
get asked to be the token lady anymore
and so it's good
peter
you're married aren't you that's true in
fact i am married to a libertarian uh
who i met in the backyard
of uh
a blogger house party in washington dc
and i'm not gonna say who but definitely
uh someone that catherine was debating
with uh no um i think i know who it is
but uh i'll just say that um you know
check the uh substance charts um
so uh
i don't know why i get mocked by the way
[Music]
so my wife is a libertarian journalist
and writes about this sort of thing but
also as a i i i think it's fair to say
applies her libertarian philosophy uh
somewhat differently than i do at times
uh and does that mean that you pay for
sex
wow just ask we were so close to this
podcast i don't know
i mean everything markets and everything
markets and everything right in some
sense it's like market-based management
but for
the currency you're using that's true
yeah i really hope that we only have
mets
[Laughter]
all of this is happening uh no it's it's
valuable to have somebody else in the
house who
thinks in uh from the same principles as
catherine was saying but applies them
differently and because we both write
about this stuff all the time we talk
about this sort of thing all the time
and i think that that is um
i think that's something that helps it
it keeps me thinking right it's it's not
just that uh so i don't just sort of
show up to work and and then like stop
thinking about this stuff when i'm done
at night when we're having dinner when
we're uh you know when we're watching
succession we're talking through all of
these things um and that means that
there's always someone there to bounce
ideas off of and if you are a writer
particularly a writer particularly a
writer who sort of trafficks not just in
kind of straight formal reporting but in
ideas and concepts and sort of ways of
thinking about the world and about
politics
the best way to shape your ideas is to
have conversations with other people who
are interested in your ideas but think a
little bit differently than you and so
having someone like that is just
incredibly valuable and i think it makes
me a better thinker um a better writer
it means often that i'm exposed to ideas
and uh and and just the facts and
stories that i wouldn't have heard of
otherwise because here is somebody who
with it with a a different
set of interests a different way of
looking at the world but one that starts
from a lot of the same premises and it
and it's great strongly recommend if you
can find uh a uh you can find a fellow
libertarian journalist in the backyard
of a dc blogger house party
put a chain on it and keep it in the
basement um consensually uh of course
yes
dating i uh well i divorced from a
libertarian more of an anarchist than a
libertarian and i've had long-term
relationships mostly
yeah in the past
25 30 years have been the long-term
relationships i've had have been with
libertarians so i feel like we're
rubbing it in i know just between us it
was like is it gonna be okay if i don't
find a libertarian yeah it's like the
libertarian lady is is already taken but
um yeah it's it's i think
libertarian ladies before i met this
what what i would
say to this gentleman no was it peter
was this thing yeah yeah what peter what
i would say is first off like don't
worry about this kind of stuff so much
be interesting and be uh you know
if you if you're interesting yourself
and you're interested in other people
good things will happen to you i don't
think that um
necessarily like being in a relationship
with a libertarian is the be-all and
end-all and you want to be with somebody
who is you know who you are compatible
with and politics can do that but it's
also
sometimes you want something different
you know or i mean and part of me for me
part of the libertarian philosophy is
the idea that it's a refuge from
politics like you know you're not always
talking about politics you're not always
talking about this it's pre-political
and if you find somebody who is
interested in kind of a laissez-faire
kind of light you know approach to the
world they don't need to be
you know libertarian in some way or
mezizian or you know hayekian or
anything like that i think it's you know
mostly you find somebody who you have a
lot you share a lot of interest with and
a certain compatibility on a broad level
of like do you want to live in a world
that is more open or less open you know
that's
um
you sir have the most instructive
relationship i think at all
uh married to french woman as
people might no um no i i wouldn't
describe uh emmanuel as libertarian but
she is a donor um and how long have you
guys have been married people will do
that too yeah if you go to reason.com
matt's wife cool cool um you can uh
donate to our url does not work i want
to be clear
you have been married for uh
you know we've been married for 24 years
uh the next what are we still in 2021 so
next year will be our uh whatever the 25
year anniversary is it's good to know
how long the uh boulders are the gold
the gold or is it the paper gold's gonna
be like 50. so now silver is 50. since i
never gave her an engagement ring i
guess it's like
it's time to it could be the time she
should give you one it should be an
equal exchange that's a an excellent
anyways we met in we met in eastern
europe uh where we lived uh and uh not a
libertarian but uh but you know you
lived in eastern europe
have you ever talked or written about
middle europa really um uh
we got this shot lord of the rings we
had the
uh you know commonality on the big
question which communism sucks and um
and you know she's french but and and
has french tastes and things like health
care systems uh but at least
you my my friend uh it's more
complicated than that as readers will uh
know i'll let the search button be your
guide uh but uh she hasn't lived in
france as an adult uh basically since
the age of 21 and there's a reason for
that um like she's attracted she's now
an american citizen she's attracted to
the uh the more free and wide open
american uh life like this is common
among french expats here like there
isn't just one school that you have to
go to that sends you in this direction
you can just kind of keep reinventing
she reinvents it as a private
investigator midway through her
journalistic career so uh we have those
big things in common um you bonded over
among other things the cure right uh
yeah i mean she was a uh and is uh but
like she was a member of the
international cure fan club
secretary and wrote about it and i like
you i've been to a few of the cure-free
concerts not as many but what i'm
getting at is that you're you share a
broadly consistent world view but it's
it was other interests then certainly
than politics or ideology yeah probably
had more to do with journalism and uh
and uh and central europe but also
economies are bad and life should be fun
and filled with uh adventure and seeking
i think which is a pretty good uh
first approximate order of uh
libertarian worldview a pre-political
worldview right life should be fun and
open and uh innovative
yes um i think that's all the dating
tips that we're going to have time for
the rousing ending of a real
i mean
if we're gonna make each other awkward
we should have listeners making us
awkward uh as well um thank you again
for getting to the bottom of this
catherine is there anything they should
know or think about right at the end of
this uh yeah yeah one thing that occurs
to me is that we are having a webathon
and so people should consider donating
to it matt um is that a tax deductible
it is a tax deductible donation and uh
your donation uh not only gets you some
cool swag but also supports the
important work that reason does to make
the world safe for free minds and free
markets and you can bid on pixelated
versions of our faces
nick yeah
go to uh if you go to reason.com you
will get a link to the nft the ra reason
roundtable nft which is currently being
auctioned off by one of our trustees of
the nonprofit reason foundation ted
barnett has a long history in tech
it's a wonderful shot of the four of us
the reason roundtable crew in beautiful
pixelated 8-bit form um you know you
need to know a little bit about uh nfts
and about ethereum in particular it's
not that complicated
it's less complex it's less complicated
than most video games uh you can learn
how to
already like
lose all of the money that you've
invested in crypto uh you know it'll
take like one or two hours to blow it
all on our
rnft it's a unique piece of history uh
and reason is a magazine that likes to
make history so
a couple shops and eve online yeah and
make a bid you can also just give us
your crypto directly that's true again
you accept many forms and we take fiat
even no we're not particularly at this
point you can send us an envelope of
cash honestly whatever you want and also
make sure to uh put uh those little
things in comments um as you're donating
uh send us a comment uh what what do you
like what got you here um suggestions
and things like that i'd mentioned i
guess offhandedly that people should
send limericks yeah and you did we got
some good ones you did i'm just gonna
read one from bob uh uh bob from
illinois
also known as uh on twitter at
the purple pros pros
like professionals
[Music]
on a recent round table most dreadful
the hosts were each rendered forgetful
like a smollette assault the pod
screeched to a halt on a welchian
transitional word pretzel
bob that's good you win you in the
pocket you don't have to donate we want
your money but we will accept your
limericks all right uh thanks everyone
goodbye
[Music]